Ultrabook: Inspired by Intel.
...unicorns, zebras, you in your underwear, in space.
This is the perfect project for you right now.
Where are you going?
We all have our hidden passions.
For Megan Fox, this is a passion for marine life.
That's why we designed the new Acer Aspire S7 Ultrabook,...
...so Megan could follow her dream and talk to dolphins.
...that would enable us to start to hear dolphins in an entirely new way.
Brilliant!
You're brilliant.
Hi, everybody!
Oh, welcome!
And this is Zenya.
Hi!
How's it going?
Try increasing the high frequency by ten percent.
Are the microphones in position?
Egg.
Oh yeah.
Fish.
I don't know what this one is either.
She stopped close to him, her hands rose, and dropped on his shoulder.
Hey, should we try this again?
Let's go.
Zenya?
We need to adjust there.
Hello.
Hello Megan.
Don't I get a hug?